joe biden does not believe that men
that women rather are better than men
joe biden does not trust women to do
men's jobs
joe biden does not trust women even to
be
women he wants men to be
women dr rachel levine
a biden appointee to be the
assistant secretary for health at
hhs was just confirmed
by the senate despite rachel's name
rachel is a man who identifies as a
woman
and he has become the first openly
transgender
federal official confirmed by the senate
and i will
say this because i you know obviously i
don't bear any ill will toward
this guy but the the whole issue is
a little uh not quite right so i'll just
i'll just describe to you what happened
in the most
clinical basic terms i can
in our country in our government
a man who thinks that he is a woman
has become one of the leaders of the
department of health
that is a monty python sketch that act
that actually
is a monty python sketch if you've ever
watched the life of brian you will see
this
gender issue come into stark light
why are you always on about women stan
i want to be one
what i want to be a woman
from now on i want you all to call me
loretta
what it's my right as a man well why'd
you want to be loretta stan
i want to have babies you want to have
babies it's every man's right to have
babies if he wants them
but you can't have babies don't you
oppress me
i'm not pressing you stan you i've got a
womb
where's the fetus gonna just take you're
gonna keep it in a box
here i've got an idea suppose you agree
that he can't actually have babies
not having a womb which is nobody's
fault not even the romans
but that he can have the right to have
babies
good idea judith we shall fight the
oppressors for your right to have babies
brother
sister sorry what's the point
what what's the point of finding dries
right to our babies when he can't have
babies
it is symbolic of our struggle against
oppression
it is like i'm watching a documentary it
is like i am
watching an actual news report of of our
culture right now and
monty python is making such an important
point in here
not even just about the the ridiculous
idea that a man can become a woman but
about
the the language that we use to describe
our rights i mean this
appointment of a man who thinks he's a
woman to be one of the leaders of our
health department
is being hailed as a great
victory for rights the rights of of
people who
some people actually suffer from this
psychological condition where
they think that they're the opposite sex
or they very much desire to be the
opposite sex
and some people are just kind of doing
it because it's fashionable now but this
is being hailed as a big win for the
rights
what right you can't have a right to
something that is not
possible logically you can't
but we talk about it this way we say he
has a right
to be a woman he can't be a woman it's
not
possible it's in in the nature of what
it is to be a man
and what it is to be a woman the man
cannot be a woman
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]